he has been in a ton of films that we
all love and for certainly sports fans
the rookie any given Sunday also
everybody's all-american and Breaking
Away is one of the most beautiful films
of all time and it's obviously about
cycling as well this man is also got his
own podcast called the Dennis anse which
premiered earlier in April and airs
every single Wednesday with a new with a
new episode and the episode that becomes
available today is with Albert Pujols he
is the host of the Dennis anse Dennis
Quaid back here on the show how are you
Dennis
great how you doing I'm doing fine um
how do you know Albert Pujols Dennis let
me just jump in right here ah yes yeah
I've had a very lucky life rich I seven
yeah been able to to meet a lot of
really interesting people in my life yes
and those are the people I had on the
Denison's Albert Pujols I did a movie in
the Dominican Republic last year and
that's where he's from he has a
foundation worried
he helped support and improved the lives
of people who are living in what they
call bought days in sugar cane fields
there and I decided to get involved
because he was the job that he was doing
there and of course I've always been a
fan of him from baseball and so with one
of his foundation galas last year and we
we became acquaintances friends and and
the relationships developed and I
thought it'd be a very interesting guest
and uh give me a little preview what do
you what do you guys talk about you talk
about a possibility of a baseball season
or do you just talk talk about okay oh
yeah the about whether there is going to
be baseball and when it's going to be
and what it's going to be and how this
is affected him he's a you know a good
arguably arguably be the oldest guy in
baseball right now out there playing and
what it's going to do to his season and
you know the records that
that you would be able to achieve and
just it's you know and he's just a
hall-of-fame guy that's person to begin
with and he's a shoo-in for the Hall of
Fame that's for sure no doubt about that
I mean as you pointed out a Hall of Fame
person do you want to tease disease does
he think that there's going to be a
baseball season everybody wants to still
think that way everybody's you know
training that way at home or whatever
they did they can do you know they were
preseason in Arizona when they just sent
everybody home nicest like it how
disheartening for all of us you know I'm
I've heard talk about that they were may
do a season of baseball but in Arizona
all the teams would be in Arizona or in
in Florida and there would be no they
would disregard the National League and
American League and basically play each
other geographically I think I mean is
that what you've heard yeah I mean it
again it's just so up in the air and and
man I it's funny because you know I'm
watching on ESPN every now and then
they've got South Korea's baseball
league which has been able to be up and
running it's not nearly as large a
country obviously and not nearly as
large of a league is Major League
Baseball but I'm just seeing the pitches
and the crack of the bats and the swings
and the homeruns and I'm like oh my god
I'd like to that's right I felt the same
thing to Dennis you know what I mean and
I know you're a golfer too and it's
possible to get golf back and in June
and I know that tiger and Phil are gonna
team up with Brady and Peyton Manning in
a couple weeks and I I can't wait for
that possibility to looks like it it
looks like it yeah you know so Dennis
Quaid here on the Rich Eisen show the
Dennis anse podcast can be gotten where
all podcasts are are gotten and it's
been out there since the early part of
April and it runs all the way through
the
early part of June you can check them
out with Albert pools today are you
gonna have Lawrence Taylor on there
you're gonna get LT on your podcast
really good don't be you know I did a
any given Sunday with LC and and also
Jim Brown
am I being paid how about a reunion show
with that that would be that would be
good and Jamie Foxx yes what if my
memory of doing that movie would be
every morning because Oliver Stone
didn't really like to start shooting
until kind of around noon we all had to
be ready before it got to be where uh at
dawn we would meet at Doral we shot it
you know down there Miami Beach or Alba
foursome was myself Jim Brown LT and
Jimmy woods and we would go out and do
battle on the golf course before we went
to work it was it was had such a great
time shooting a movie
well maybe Oliver Stone was told by
Lawrence Taylor I'm unavailable until
noon I mean that could have been it you
know it could have been LT just tell her
Lori Taylor is available anytime like
just like house clothing or shorts kind
of like gym shorts and flip-flops right
and where two gloves and you know it
doesn't how much sleepy dad he could hit
the ball bat competitor who's the
battery had the greatest offensive
player and the greatest defensive player
arguably of all time out there out there
teeing off who is the best who's the
best athlete player you've ever played
with Dennis from maybe happily player
yeah yeah
as far as all f---ing yes sir but you've
ever got aired up with yeah I you know
LT was help he was he was really good I
mean he was like I say coming out there
he just he could get it done this is
such a competitive Jim Brown at that
time was actually really good as well
really really good well I mean with Jim
can I thought Tori Aiken was rather was
excellent and record about yeah and but
a number of them I'm sure all players
make a baseball players especially
pitchers make really good golfers
because they don't they don't have to
work everyday that's right every fifth
day they get out there and four days in
between I mean that's why you know the
the great Atlanta Braves staff of Maddux
Smoltz Glavine they're apparently they
were all scratch golfers you know what
it all comes down to it hey man the
rookie is such a beautiful film Dennis
from your from your sports film ography
and that's a movie where I have cried on
airplanes watching that you know of like
literally I start crying I've watched
the rookie on an airplane and I just
start crying about the story about Jim
Morris a teacher getting a shot in the
major leagues what was it like meeting
him he was going to set every day and
that's what I mean about my life your
life the people I've really been able to
really get to know in fact he's a guest
on money on my podcast and the Sox had
him on we did the interview a couple of
weeks ago and it'll be it'll be coming
out here within the next few weeks and
again we till we talk about baseball and
we talked about you know just could
dived a little deeper into and do you
know what his life after the rookie
mmm-hmm yeah when after the movie came
out he's such an inspiration and what
was it a true story that or that was
just a dignified version that well in
terms of going out there and using a
side of the road speedometer to test how
fast he through is that was that was
that a real that that yeah that never
happened
I love Dennis I love it that never
happened with the you know he came up as
a seven when it should have been an iron
right and it's also true that I never
put myself on a on a radar gun when I
was you during the whole film you want
to be disappointed I'd want to be
disappointed so how look like I could do
it how fast could you throw that come on
now what you don't know I put myself on
a radar gun so I'm going to say 90 miles
boy damn straight I do you talk 90 I
probably would have been lucky to be
really be at the 70 I put a bow I bet
you touch 90 no doubt about it what's
the film what's the film you get the
most Dennis when you're out and about or
when what I'm out about well the rookie
is right up there that's for sure and
I'm kind of my career is kind of
multi-generational at this point you
know that's because of the film where
people were kids in a particular
generation The Parent Trap is huge
mm-hmm of course and Innerspace is
surprising like surprisingly the number
one movie that I get as far as worldwide
know gonna go I've been in the you know
backwoods of India and I heard somebody
say Innerspace yeah it's surprising and
Breaking Away though you know when we
talk sports movies that kind of gets
lost I'll be honest with you because
maybe it's not just about sports it's
just involved a sport and involved yeah
but what was the Kareem abdul-jabbar put
that in his top five sports movies of
all time no kidding and but it's a movie
I watched it a couple of weeks ago
because we're doing a reunion with all
the breaking or a waiting with such
charity
zooms for charity or something like that
like yeah and well for the podcast
well Golding just to get together and
amazing had hopefully Lance Armstrong is
gonna be the bottom well that would be
good Dennis that's not a bad get I mean
yeah that that'd be great
I'll be out there but that was that
movie had such charm it was you know it
was written by a first-generation
Czech emigrant it was directed by an
Englishman and it's such a a great
American like middle of heart of America
Americana story that has such charm to
it and still holds up it's beautiful it
is I'm glad I brought it up with you hey
Dennis I appreciate the call man
Congrats on your pod you know if you're
gonna continue doing it
I'd love to complete a home at home
you've been so kind to come on my show
in person and also here on the phone if
you ever you ever need a guest aww I'll
be more than happy to
oh I pitch in there man appreciate that
man I really looked
I'd like to dive into your life away
from the show I'm I'm all-in
I'm all-in I'm I'm I'm not that terribly
interesting I'm not like Lawrence Taylor
like octene off the top of a Camaro or
something like that I mean I can't tell
stories like that but I'll I'll try and
compete well I've always enjoyed being a
show rich and thanks for still being
there going down to the studio and and
keeping it going and we're gonna all get
through this and I think we're be even
stronger for it I I hope so and I
believe so too thanks for the call
Dennis you take care of yourself that's
alright god bless you right back atcha
that's Dennis Quaid check out that you
bet senior that's to check out the
Dennis anse podcast Albert Pujols is
ladies guest fabulous